francis collins wrote a letter in
october 2020
to anthony fauci anything somebody else
i have um
the letter oh it's not a letter email i
apologize
uh hi tony and cliff
c
gb declaration.org
this proposal
this is the great barrington declaration
that you're a co-author on this proposal
from the three fringe epidemiologists
who met with the secretary seemed to be
getting a lot of attention and even a
co-signature from nobel prize winner
mike levitt at stanford there needs to
be a quick and devastating published
takedown
of its premises
i don't see anything like that online
yet is it underway question mark francis
francis collins director of the nih
somebody i talked to on this podcast
recently
okay
a million questions i want to ask but
first how did that make you feel when
you first
saw this uh email come to uh
uh to light which when when when did it
come to light uh this week actually i
think or last week okay so this is
because of freedom of information yeah
which by the way
sort of um
maybe because i do want to add positive
stuff on on the side of francis here
um
boy when i see stuff like that i wonder
if all my emails leaked
how much embarrassing stuff like i think
i'm a good person but i don't
i haven't read my old emails maybe i'm
pretty sure sometimes later i could be
an [ __ ]
well i mean i look he's a christian and
i'm a christian i'm supposed to forgive
right i mean i think
he was looking at this
great barrington declaration as a
political problem to be solved
as opposed to a serious alternative
approach to the epidemic
so maybe we'll talk about in more detail
but just for for in case people are not
familiar great barrington declaration
was
was was a document
that you co-authored
that basically argues against this idea
of lockdown as a solution to covid and
you propose another solution that we'll
talk about but the point is
it's not
that dramatic of a document
it is just a document that criticizes
one policy solution but it was the
policy solution that had been put
forward by
dr collins and by tony fauci
and a few other a few other science not
i mean i think a relatively small number
of scientists and epidemiologists in
charge of
the advice given to governments
worldwide
and it was a challenge to that policy
that said that look there there is an
alternate path that the path we've
chosen this path of lock down with an
aim to suppress the virus to zero
effectively i mean that was unstated
cannot work and is causing catastrophic
harm to
large numbers of poor and vulnerable
people worldwide
we put this out in october 4th i think
of 2020
and
it went viral i mean i've never actually
been involved with anything like like
this where i just put the document on
the web
and tens of thousands of doctors signed
on hundreds of thousands of regular
people signed on
it it really struck a accord of uh
people because i think even by october
of 2020 people had this sense that there
was something really wrong
with the coveted policy that we've been
following
and they were looking for
reasonable people to give an alternative
i mean we're not arguing that covet
doesn't isn't a serious thing i mean it
is a very serious thing this is why we
we had a policy that aimed at addressing
it
um
we were but we were saying that the
policy we're following is not the right
one
so how does a democratic
uh government deal with that
challenge
uh so to me that you asked me how i felt
i was actually frankly just i was i i
suspected there had been some email
exchanges like that not necessarily from
francis collins
around the government around this
time
i mean i felt the full brunt of a
propaganda campaign
almost immediately after we published it
where newspapers mischaracterized it in
all in the same the same way over and
over and over again
um and sought to
characterize me as sort of a as a sort
of a marginal fringe figure or whatnot
and me and sinatra grouped martin cool
door for the tens of thousands of other
people that signed it
i felt the brunt of that
all year long
so to see this in black and white in you
know with the handwriting essentially if
i mean the the metaphorical handwriting
of francis collins was actually frankly
a disappointment because i've looked up
to him for years
yeah i've looked up them as well
i
um
i mean i look for the the best in people
and
i still look up to him
what troubles me is several things
the reason i said about the
the [ __ ] emails that i send late at
night
is um
i can understand this email
it's fear it's panic not being sure
the fringe three fringe epidemiologists
mike levitt who won a nobel prize i mean
but using fringe
maybe in my private thoughts i have said
things like that about others
like a little bit too unkind
like you don't really mean it
now add to that
he
recently this week whatever
uh
double down on the fringe
this is really troubling to me
that like i can excuse this email but
to see the arrogance there
i that francis honestly i mean broke my
heart a little bit there this was an
opportunity to like especially at this
stage
to say
just like i told him um
to say i was wrong to use those words in
that email
i was i was wrong
to not be open to ideas
i still believe that this is not like
say
like actually argue with the with the
proposal with the policy of the proposed
uh solution also
the devastating publish take devastating
takedown
devastating takedown as you say somebody
who's sitting
on billions of dollars
that they're giving to scientists
some of whom are often not their best
human beings because they're fighting
with each other over money not being
cognizant of the fact that you're
challenging the integrity you're
corrupting the integrity of scientists
by allocating the money
you're now playing with that
by saying devastating takedown
where do you think the published
takedown will come from it will come
from those scientists to whom you're
giving money what kind of example would
they give to the academic community that
thrives on freedom like this this is
i believe francis collins is a great man
one of the things i was troubled by is
the negative response to him from people
that don't understand the positive
impact that nih has had on society how
many people has helped but this is
exactly the so he's not just a scientist
he's not just a bureaucrat who
distributes money he's also a scientific
leader
that in the time in difficult times we
live in is supposed to inspire us with
trust with love with
the freedom of thought he's supposed to
you know those fringe epidemiologists
those are the heroes of science when you
look at the long arc of history we love
those people
we love ideas even when they get proven
wrong that's what always had attracted
me to science like some somebody like
the the lone voice saying oh no the the
the moon of jupiter does move
yeah i mean you know but the funny thing
is you know galileo is saying something
truly revolutionary we were saying
that what we proposed in great britain
declaration was actually just the old
pandemic plan
it wasn't anything really
fundamentally novel
um in fact there were plans like this
that
lockdown scientists had written in late
february early march of 2020 so we were
not saying anything radical we were just
calling for a debate
effectively over the existing lockdown
policy
and this is a disappointment a really
truly a big disappointment because
by doing this
you were absolutely right lex he sent a
signal
to so many other scientists to just stay
silent even if you had reservations
yeah devastating takedown the people you
know how many people wrote to me
privately like stanford mit
how amazing
the conversation with francis collins
was
there's a kind of admiration
because
okay how do i put it
a lot of people
get into science because they want to
help the world
they get excited by the ideas and they
and they they really are working hard to
help in whatever the discipline is and
then there is sources of funding
which help you do help at a larger scale
so you admire those the people that uh
um
are distributing the money because
they're often
at least on the surface are really also
good people oftentimes they're great
scientists so like it's amazing i that's
why i'm sort of um
like sometimes people from outside think
academia is broken some kind of way no
it's it's a beautiful thing it's a it's
really is a beautiful thing and that's
why it's so deeply heartbreaking with
this person
um is um i don't think this is
malevolence
i think he's just incompetence of
communication
uh twice i think there's there's also
arrogance at the bottom of it too so
like but all of us have arrogance yes
there's a particular kind of arrogance
right so here it's it's of the same kind
of arrogance that you see when tony
fauci gets on tv and says
that uh that if you criticize me you're
not simply criticizing a man you're
criticizing science itself right right
that is at the heart also of this email
this so the certainty
that the policies that they were
recommending collins and fauci were
recommending to the president of the
united states were right not just right
but right so so far right that any
challenge whatsoever to it is dangerous
um and i think that that is really the
heart of that email it's it's um it's
this idea that
my position is unchallengeable
now to be to be completely to be as
charitable as i can be to this you know
i believe they thought that i believe
they some of them still think that that
that there was only one true policy
possible in response to coving every
other policy was immoral
and if you if you come from that
position then you write an email like
that you go on tv you say effectively
right i mean that that is that is what
happens when you have this sort of
unchallengeable arrogance that the
policy you're following is correct
i mean when we wrote the great bank
declaration
what i was hoping for
was a discussion
about how to protect the vulnerable i
mean that was the key idea to me in the
whole thing was better protection of the
older population who really at really
serious risk if infected with covid and
we had been doing a very poor job i
thought to date in many places in
protecting the vulnerable
and what i wanted was a discussion by
local public health
about better methods better policies to
protect the vulnerable
so when when i was when we were met with
instead a series of essentially
propagandist lies about it so they for
instance i kept hearing from reporters
in in those days why do you want to let
the virus rip let it rip let it rip the
words let it rip
does not appear in the great barrington
declaration
the goal isn't to let the virus rip um
the the goal is to protect the
vulnerable
to let society go
as you know open schools and do other
things that it
functions as best it can in the midst of
a terrible pandemic yes
but not let the virus rip
where no the most vulnerable are
protected the goal was to protect the
vulnerable so why let it rip because it
was a propaganda term to hit the fear
centers of people's brains oh these
people are immoral they just want to let
the virus go through society and hurt
everybody that was that was that was the
idea this it it was a way to preclude a
discussion and precluded debate about
the existing policy
so i've uh
this is an app called
clubhouse um i've gone back on it
recently
to practice russian unrelated for for a
few big russian conversations coming up
anyway it's a great way to talk to
regular people in russian but i also
there was a i was nervous i was
preparing for a pfizer ceo conversation
and there was a vaccine room and so i
joined it
uh and there's a there's a pro science
room as they they these are like
scientists that were calling each other
pro science
the whole thing was like theater to me i
mean i haven't thoroughly researched but
looking at the resume they were like
pretty solid
researchers and doctors
and they were mocking
everybody
who was at all i mean it doesn't matter
what they stood for but they were just
mocking people and the arrogance was
overwhelming i had to shut off
because i couldn't handle that human
beings can be like this to each other
and then i i went back just to double
check is this really happen how many
people are here is this theater
and then i uh asked to come on stage on
clubhouse to make a couple comments and
then as i open my mouth and say thank
you so much you know this is this is a
great room sort of the usual civil
politeness all that kind of stuff
and
i said i'm worried that
the kind of arrogance with which
things are being discussed here
will further divide us not
unite us and and before
i said even the united further divide us
i was thrown off stage now this isn't
where i mentioned platform but like i am
like
lex friedman mit
uh also
which is something most people seem to
sometimes care about the followers and
stuff like that like did you just do
that and then they said enough of that
nonsense
enough of that nonsense they said to me
enough of that nonsense
somebody who is obviously interviewed
francis collins
is uh uh the pfizer ceo uh
potential epidemiologist also so just
yeah exactly but this broke my heart the
arrogance and this is echoes of that
arrogance is something you see in this
email and i really would love to have a
million things to talk about to try to
figure out how can we find a path
forward i think a lot of
a lot of the problems
we've seen in the
the discussion over cove especially in
the scientific community you know
there's there's two ways to look at
science i think uh that that have been
competing with each other for a while
now
uh one way and this is the way that i
view science and why i've always found
it so attractive is an invitation to a
structured discussion
where uh the discussion is tempered by
by evidence by data by by
reasoning and logic
right so it's a dialectical process
where if i believe a and you believe b
well uh we talk about it we come up with
an experiment that distinguishes between
the two
and while you know b turns out to be
right i'm i'm all frustrated but i buy
you dinner and i say no no no c and then
we go on from there right that's that's
what science is at its best it's this
process of using data in discussion it's
a human activity
right uh to to to learn
to let have the truth unfold itself
before us
on the other hand there are
there's another way that people have
used science or thought about science as
a as truth in and of itself
right this like if it's if it's science
therefore it's true automatically and
they're the you know what does the
science say to do well the science never
says to do anything the science says
here's what's true and then we have to
apply our human values
to say okay well if we do this well then
this is likely to happen that's what the
science says if we do that then that is
likely to happen well we'd rather have
this than that right and but it doesn't
does science doesn't tell us that we'd
rather have this than that is there
human values that tell us that we'd
rather this and that science plays a
role but it's not the only thing
it's not the only role it's like it
helps us understand the constraints we
face but it doesn't tell us what to do
in face of those constraints but
underneath it at the individual level at
the institutional level it seems like
um
arrogance
is really destructive so the flip side
of that the productive thing is humility
so sort of um
um always not being
sure that you're right
this is actually kind of uh stuart
russell talks about this for ai research
how do you make sure that ai super
intelligent ai doesn't destroy us you
built in um
a sort of module within it that it
always doubts
its actions like it's not sure
like i know it says i'm supposed to
destroy all humans but maybe i'm wrong
and that maybe i'm wrong is essential
for progress for actually doing in the
long arc of history better not the
perfect thing but better and better and
better and better i mean the the
question i have here for you is
this i i that this email so clearly
captures some
maybe echo but maybe a core to the
problem
do you put responsibility of this email
of the shortcomings
and failures on individuals or
institutions is this college
no this is an institutional failure
right so um the nih i i've had two
decades of nih funding i've sat on nih
review panels
the purpose of the nih is what you said
earlier lex the purpose of nih is to
support the work of scientists to some
extent it's also how to help scientists
to direct scientists to work on things
that are very important for public
health or for the health of the public
um so and the way you do that is you say
okay we're going to put you know 50
million dollars on uh the research in
alzheimer's disease this year or 70
million dollars on hiv or whatever it is
right some and
that pot of money then uh scientists
compete with each other for the best
ideas to to use it to address that that
problem
so it's essentially an endeavor to
support the work of scientists it is not
in and of itself a policy organ
it doesn't say what public health policy
should be
for that you have the cdc
and
what happened during the pandemic is
that
people
in the nih were called upon
to contribute to public health
policymaking
and that created the conflict of
interest you see in that email
right so now you have
the head of the nih
in effect saying to all scientists you
must agree with me
in the policy that i've recommended
or else you're fringe
that is a deep conflict of interest it's
deep because first he he's conflicted he
has this dual role as
as as the head of the nih
supporter of scientific funding and then
also
inappropriately called to set or help
set
pandemic policy
that should never have happened there
should be a bright line between those
two roles
let me ask you about just francis
collins i don't know if you i i had a
chance to talk to him on a podcast i
don't know if you maybe by chance gotten
a chance to hear a few words of it
um well i have a kind of a question uh
to that because a lot of people
wrote to me quite negative things about
francis collins and like i said i still
believe
he's a great man a great scientist
um
one of the things when i
talked to him off mike
about the vaccine
the excitement he had about when we were
recollecting
when they first got in an inkling that
it's actually going to be possible to
get a vaccine just he wasn't messaging
just in the private or of our own
conversation he was really excited and
why was he excited because he gets to
help a lot of people this is a man
that really wants to help people and
there could be some institutional
self-delusion the arrogance all those
kinds of things that lead to this kind
of email but ultimately the the goal is
this is what i don't think people quite
realize this
the reason you call your fringe
epidemiologist the reason there needs to
be a devastating uh published takedown
he i believe really believes
that this it could be very dangerous
and
it's a lot of burden to carry on his
shoulders because like you said in his
role where he defines some of the public
policy
like
you know depending on how he thinks
about the world millions of people could
die because of one decision he make yeah
and that's a lot of burden to walk with
yeah no i think that's right i don't
think that he has bad intentions
i think that he was basically put was
put or maybe put himself in a position
where
this kind of conflict of interest was
going to create this kind of this this
kind of reaction
right the kind of humility that you're
calling for is almost impossible when
you have that dual dual role this that
shouldn't you shouldn't have to have as
as funder of science and also center of
scientific policy i agree with
everything you just said except the last
part the the humility is almost
impossible that
uh
humility is always difficult i think
i think there's a huge incentive to for
humility in that position now look at
history
great leaders that have humility
um are popular as hell so if you like
being popular
if you like having impact legacy uh
these descendants of apes seem to care
about legacy especially as they get
older in these high positions like i i
think the incentive for humility is
pretty high well i mean the thing is is
like there's a lot that he has to be
proud of in his career i mean like the
human genome project wouldn't have
happened without him uh and he is he is
a great man and a great scientist but so
it is tragic to me that his career has
ended in this particular way
you